les érogène de plaisir prennent de l'âge
mais aucun complexe de vieillesse pour
ce club d'ultimate fondée en 1997
depuis cette date cette activité attire
de plus en plus de licenciés
à la base le club comptait une dizaine
d'adhérents mais a tout de suite
participé au championnat et cette année
en 2017 géant compte plus de 50 environ
54 adhérents 40 adultes et environ 15
juniors les vingt ans coïncide aussi
avec une ouverture de la section juniors
donc avec une section jeunes a titré
avec un entraînement extérieur et même
hier ils ont pu la possibilité pouvoir
jouer ensemble entre juniors ça fait 12
ans que je suis dans le club
c'est vrai que c'est émouvant de voir
qu'on arrive aux 12 au 20 ans pardon
maintenant on espère comme je vous
disais beaucoup plus on arrive à avoir
de plus en plus de licenciés le sport
commence à se faire connaître également
donc c'est plutôt que du positif pour
fêter leurs vingt ans les plaisirs oies
ont profité de la 13e édition de leur
tournoi local baptisé zéro peine huit
équipes une centaine de joueurs venus de
la région francilienne
un niveau assez relevé notamment avec
les tsunamis du loin de nemours
finaliste de cette compétition
nous on est une équipe avec certains
joueurs qui jouent depuis de nombreuses
années et d'autres plus débutants et
le niveau oui le niveau et est bon on
verra pour la finale finalement les
tsunamis du loing se sont inclinés face
à l'équipe expérimentée des moufles d'or
plaisir termine avant dernier du tournoi
un résultat anecdotique les érogènes ont
célébré leur anniversaire sans aucun
complexe d'infériorité